being in the media industry in Nigeria
and across Africa is a very exciting
time number one is I think the biggest
part is how people are telling stories
and the different stories were telling
but I think also the most exciting thing
is the role that digital media will have
to play and I'm when I say digital media
I talk about social media I'm talking
about the fact that people are creating
their own content what YouTube is doing
so I feel that the the most exciting
thing is the way Africans are gonna be
telling the African story going forward
I mean I think actually if you take
something that actually happened
recently and so that is really the the
hostage situation that happened in
Nairobi Kenya so this was obviously
something that was happening in Kenya
but it was people were able to see it
from a multiple perspectives right away
so for example from the traditional news
outlets you saw it but then you also saw
it from Facebook and you were able to
track what was happening on Twitter and
this is something that wasn't really
easily available in Africa before the
explosion of mobile phones so not only
was this an event that was confined to
Kenya was an event that was felt all
around Africa but it was also an event
that people were able to communicate and
also console and also really have the
information about who's who's involved
in where they are but at the same time
it was also saying okay now that we have
all this technology how do we put a
human face to this and then there was
these public appeals to say look can we
please exercise some sort of decorum in
dissent in disseminating this
information so I think that those are
examples where there's a democratization
of information and this distribution of
information but now how also do we self
censor ourselves so I think those are
gonna be some of the new things that we
struggle with in this new exciting world
of information and the distribution of
information